Hey everyone, Ryan here!
This video is on a topic that many of you have been asking for.
So some exciting things were happening at the Euro-Period9 conference in June of 2018.
The American Academy of Peridontology, or the AAP, officially announced a new Peridontal
classification system.
And the guidelines had previously not been updated since 1999.
So this is a pretty big deal.
Additionally, the Integrated National Board dental exam is exclusively using this new
classification system.
So I'm here to cover it for you and help you feel comfortable using it to diagnose
patient cases.
So let's look at a brief history of Peridontal classifications.
In the mid-1970s, we started with chronic marginal versus juvenile periodontitis.
In the mid-1980s, that's changed to adult and juvenile periodontitis.
And then shortly after, they added in more specific categories, like Type N through
Type V.
In the late 1990s, they introduced chronic and aggressive periodontitis, which we've
used for roughly two decades, and then announced in 2017 and implemented in 2018, the staging
and grading system is the newest one we have, and the one we'll spend the most time on in
this video.
So the major changes implemented at this conference is that there are now four main categories
of disease processes.
These are periodontal health and gingival diseases and conditions, periodontitis, period
implant diseases and conditions, and periodontal manifestation of systemic diseases and developmental
and acquired conditions.
Now we're going to focus on the first three in this video in that order.
So we start with periodontal health.
Now if things get worse, that turns to gingivitis, and if things get worse still, that turns to
periodontitis.
Now periodontal health and gingival diseases only includes these first two, so let's focus
on those to start with.
The case definition of periodontal health is healthy, soft, and hard tissue surrounding
the teeth.
That being said, some amount of inflammation is acceptable because let's face it, no one's
perfect.
So localized, minimal, and delayed bleeding on probing at isolated sites is hard to avoid
and may fall within the spectrum of clinical health.
Now that could be minimal bleeding on probing at less than 10% of sites and probing depths
at three millimeters or below.
These things describe maybe one or two sites with some evidence of clinical inflammation,
but generally overall this is a situation of health.
Now this can happen on either an intact or a reduced periodontum, so let's define those
real quick.
An intact periodontum is one with no loss of periodontal tissue.
A reduced periodontum is a periodontum with pre-existing loss of periodontal tissue,
but and this is important, is not currently undergoing loss of bone or connective tissue.
So reduced periodontum could be the result of hard toothbrush scrubbing leading to gingival
recession or crown lengthening performed by a dentist.
In these cases the patient could have no periodontitis history at all.
These are things that were involving toothbrush scrubbing and crown lengthening performed by
the dentist.
So that patient may have a reduced periodontum and they never had periodontal disease at
all.
In this case, those types of patients that fall in this category have no increased risk
of periodontitis.
But reduced periodontum could also be the result of previous periodontitis that caused
the clinical attachment loss, but now the condition is currently stable because we're
in a situation of periodontal health.
By the way, periodontal stability is characterized by successful treatment through control of
local and systemic risk factors, resulting in bleeding on probing at less than 10% of
sites and probing depths at 3mm or below, and there's no progressive periodontal destruction.
So reduced periodontum, intact periodontum, both of those situations could be the result
of, or could be, included in this realm of periodontal health.
Now the case definition of gingivitis is clinical evidence of inflammation.
And this involves things like erythema, redness, edema, this is localized swelling, and bleeding
on probing.
So now we have bleeding on probing at greater than or equal to 10% of sites.
But those probing depths are still pretty controlled at 3mm or below.
Stable periodontum, again, we're not seeing the progressive loss of alveolar bone and
clinical attachment.
This is defined as gingivitis.
We're mostly focusing on the big change here is this part right here.
Bleeding on probing and these clinical signs of inflammation that are occurring at more
than just one or two sites, now it's either localized to the anterior region of the mouth
or the posterior region of the mouth, or it's generalized to the entire mouth.
Okay, so now let's move to periodontitis.
So periodontitis is defined as the loss of periodontal tissue support due to microbially
associated host-mediated inflammation.
Now we're talking about deeper probing depths and we're also talking about the presence
of interproximal attachment loss.
So much of this is the same that we've known before.
Without plaque, there is no disease.
Plaque induces an inflammatory response and the body runs away as the bone and soft tissue
attachment retreats away from that plaque.
It's evaluated through the clinical attachment or the clinical evaluation, I should say, of
attachment levels or the radiographic assessment of bone levels.
And the key here is interproximal, that's an important word in this definition.
So we're not talking so much about straight facial and straight lingual.
We're focusing more on the attachment loss in the mesial and distal areas between the
teeth.
Okay, so for periodontitis classification, the new additions are staging and grading.
So let's look at staging first.
The stage is determined by the severity and the extent of disease at presentation.
So this is a static measurement.
At this moment in time, what is that patient's presentation?
Now we'll look at things like severity, complexity, and extent and distribution and how all three
of these work together to determine your stage.
Now staging intends to classify the patient's disease based on the measurable amount of
destroyed and/or damaged tissue as the result of periodontitis and to assess the specific
factors that may attribute to the complexity of long-term case management.
Staging is measured from one to four, that's from slight to severe.
So the first thing you look at to determine staging is severity and severity is primarily
based on interdental clinical attachment loss or CAL.
CAL is measured from the CEJ, that's the Cemento enamel junction, to the base of the pocket.
And your worst interproximal CAL, that's the biggest number, the greatest loss of attachment
you have in the mouth, gives you your baseline stage.
And again, this is not straight facial or straight lingual.
We're talking about the areas in between the teeth.
So if that worst interdental CAL is one or two millimeters, that defines a stage one,
three or four, that's a stage two.
If it's five or more, then we're automatically in stage three or stage four territory.
If clinical attachment loss is not available, radiographic bone loss can be used as the
proxy instead.
And tooth loss, due to peridontitis, can shift the stage to a higher level.
If that patient's loss to a certain amount of teeth, we could bump up a stage one or
stage two to a stage three or stage four.
And we'll talk more about those specifics when we get to specific examples.
Complexity is primarily based on local factors, like probing depth, the nature of the bone
loss of its horizontal or vertical, if there's forcation involvement, if there's occlusal
trauma and bike collapse, just to name a few.
And one or more of these complexity factors can shift the stage to a higher level.
For example, if your largest probing pocket depth is five millimeters, it can upgrade
a stage one to a stage two, or if you have probing pocket depth above six millimeters
with forcation involvement, you can upgrade that to a stage three.
And if you have secondary occlusal trauma and bike collapse, you could maybe even upgrade
that patient to a stage four.
So that's how complexity factors can work.
There are also some special factors to consider if you have vertical bone loss at three millimeters
or more, that puts them at an automatic stage three or four, forcation involvement, class
two or class three, class two means you have a horizontal forcation that's greater than
three millimeters, class three means that you have a through and through forcation involvement
so you can pass that neighbors probe all the way through the forcation area.
That's an automatic stage three or four as well.
And if the patient has less than 20 teeth remaining, they're an automatic stage four.
And the last thing that goes into staging is extent and distribution.
And this is based on the percentage of teeth that are involved in that severity or complexity.
So if the patient has a localized extent and distribution, that means that less than 30
percent of their teeth are involved in that severity or complexity, generalized means
that 30 percent or more of their teeth are involved at that severity.
And a molar incisor pattern is a very specific pattern where only incisors and molars are
included.
And this is kind of our classic localized aggressive periodontitis.
So to put this in a little bit more relevant perspective, if a patient has 32 teeth, that's
all their teeth, including their wisdom teeth, then this 30 percent threshold is 10 teeth.
So the cutoff for becoming generalized is 10 teeth being affected.
If the patient had their wisdom teeth removed and they have 28 teeth, then this 30 percent
threshold is at 8 teeth, so the cutoff for becoming generalized would be if 8 teeth were
affected.
And again, if molars and incisors are exclusively involved, we instead, we don't call it localized,
we call it a molar incisor pattern to be even more specific.
So since there's no longer aggressive periodontitis, that's no longer a thing, after this new classification
system was announced, we call it molar incisor.
So you take one of these three and add it to the stage as a descriptor, so you could
call it localized stage three, or molar incisor stage four, for example.
So to put it all together, you start with the most severe interdental cal and select the
appropriate stage.
If cal is not available, you do the same thing with radiographic bone loss.
Then you look at the teeth lost due to periodontitis.
If four or less, then you upgrade to stage three.
If five or more, you upgrade to stage four.
And then you look at the local complexity factors.
So if there are factors that are appropriate to a patient like vertical bone loss greater
than three millimeters, or less than 20 remaining teeth, you would upgrade to the appropriate
stage.
Stage one is slight severity.
Stage two is moderate.
Stage three and stage four are severe.
And remember, there can only be one stage per patient, so use the most severe one.
All right now, let's talk about the grade.
So the grade is determined by the rate of disease progression, the responsiveness to
therapy, and their overall assessment of risk.
So this is based on longitudinal observation, the assessment of bone loss over time, and
other risk factors like smoking and diabetes.
So grading is a dynamic measurement, how things are changing over time.
And it aims to indicate the rate of periodontitis progression, the responsiveness to their therapy,
and potential impact on their systemic health.
So this one is measured from A to C, from slow to rapid.
Now thankfully, grading is a bit more straightforward.
And clinicians should initially assume a grade of B, and then look for specific evidence
to shift to either grade A or grade C. And just like in staging, the first row here is
the most important.
So we look at how an interdental cal or radiographic bone loss is changing over a period of five
years.
And so if it's more loss of attachment or bone loss or bone levels over this period of
five years, we're favoring more towards a rapid disease progression.
If there's not as much loss, we're more towards a slow rate of progression.
Secondarily, we can look at percent of radiographic bone loss compared to age.
So this would be like if you had a 50% bone loss for a 50-year-old patient.
That would be a ratio of 50-50, which would be 1, and a ratio of 1 would put you in grade
B. Now if you had 50% bone loss for a 25-year-old, that would be a ratio of 2, and put you at
grade C.
The case phenotype is talking about if the amount of plaque you see is consistent with
the level of disease.
So heavy biofilm deposits with low levels of destruction would be a grade A situation.
If the destruction is consistent with the biofilm deposits, that would be grade B.
And if the destruction you see exceeds the expectations given those biofilm deposits,
that's suggestive of periods of rapid progression and/or early onset disease that would put
you at a grade C situation.
For smoking the more smoking you do, the more uncontrolled your diabetes is, those things
are going to make the disease progress more rapidly.
And CRP stands for C Reactive Protein, an elevated serum, C Reactive Protein, is a systemic
marker of inflammation and a documented risk factor for cardiovascular disease and otherwise
healthy people.
So the more CRP you have, means you're at higher risk of a faster progressing disease.
So grade A is slow, grade B is moderate, grade C is rapid.
And just like with staging, you only give one grade per patient.
But since it's dynamic, the grade might change over time as risk factors are modified, and
the idea is to predict future progression, based on past progression, in the presence
of these risk factors.
So some other considerations, a peridontitis patient is a peridontitis patient for life,
and patients should not return to the level of evaluation and maintenance identical to
a patient who has never had peridontitis.
So for someone who hasn't had peridontitis, they get an annual or twice a year exam and
cleaning.
For a patient who has peridontitis, they should always be treated with a certain level of scrutiny
and maintenance in order that they don't relapse into a stage of progressive bone loss and
connective tissue loss.
And despite substantial research on aggressive peridontitis since that last 1999 workshop,
there's currently insufficient evidence to consider aggressive and chronic peridontitis
as to pathophysiologically distinct diseases.
So that distinction is no more.
Alright so let's have some fun and go over some cases.
Now I designed this patient box to mimic what you'll see on the integrated board exam.
So this could be part of a question prompt that you get.
So for this case number one, we have a male who's 50 years old.
Their chief complaint is I'm concerned about some of my front teeth that drift around.
They smoke a half pack of cigarettes every day.
They have minimal biofilm deposits, interdental cow that ranges from 2 to 8 millimeters.
The 14 teeth have interdental cow that's greater than or equal to 5 millimeters.
And then we have some clinical photos and a full mouth series of x-rays.
So with all this information that we're given, we know this patient has some kind of peridontitis.
So let's start with staging.
The most severe interdental cow is 8.
So this is greater than or equal to 5 millimeters.
So we're automatically at a stage 3 or stage 4.
We can see a couple areas where the radiographic bone loss is extending to the middle, certainly
beyond the middle third of the root.
And this confirms this severity of stage 3 or stage 4.
Now his anterior teeth, he talks about this in his CC.
The anterior teeth are moving and drifting around and that's an important statement.
We can maybe see his upper left and scissor and these two upper left and scissor are flaring
out and forward which is another sign of occlusal dysfunction, secondary to a peridontal
problem.
So that's going to bump us up to more of a stage 4 situation.
And since 14 teeth are affected by this level of severity, that's more than 30%.
That's higher than our threshold of 30%.
So this is a generalized situation.
Now for grading, we look at the rate of progression over time, which we don't have in this case.
So the next thing we have to go on is the ratio of bone loss to age.
And at our worst sites, we're probably at something like 70, 75% bone loss and so it
be even worse in the lower anterior, so 75 is more than his age of 50.
So our ratio is over 1, which would favor grade C. We also note that there's minimal
plaque which is inconsistent with our state of disease, which is fairly severe.
So that also favors a grade C. And he's smoking a half pack of cigarettes per day.
A pack of cigarettes contains 20, so he's smoking 10 per day, which also puts him in
that grade C. So let's review all of our findings we just talked about.
Here's what we have for our staging, here's what we have for our grading.
And remember that more than 30% of teeth were affected by this severity.
So we would diagnose this patient with generalized stage four grade C periodontitis.
Alright case number two, now this time we're given a periodontal chart so we can analyze
the clinical attachment loss ourselves.
Now of course if you want to, you can pause the video and work through these diagnoses
by yourself first, otherwise I'll keep going and review these so we can go through them.
Now if we do a quick scan, the worst interdental clinical attachment loss which is located
in these four rows appears to be eight.
There's an eight there and there's an eight there.
So that automatically will put us at a stage three or stage four.
Now the plus actually means that it's 10 or more but we don't count this one because
it's not interdental.
So again we look for how many teeth have an interdental cal that's five millimeters or
more to determine the extent and a distribution of the disease.
So we see an eight and a six, a six and a five.
We have a four on this premolar.
We have let's see a five that's not interdental but we have a four on that premolar as well.
We have a couple of fours, threes, some sixs down here, a five and an eight by these molars.
Looks like mostly molars are being affected here and the incisors are, they do have some
callet two and three but they're not at that same severity.
So I don't feel comfortable calling this a molar incisor pattern because it's really
just molars that are affected.
So this is definitely going to be considered a localized disease process.
Those five millimeter or more cal numbers are all occurring by the molars.
Okay, now we look for some other clues and we don't have any clinical photos or x-rays
this time so we really have to rely on the information presented in the patient box.
We see that she's an ex-smoker with a ten pack year history.
One pack year means that she has smoked one pack a day for one year.
So ten pack years means she's smoked one pack a day for ten years or she smoked a half pack
a day for 20 years or she smoked two packs a day for five years.
Any multiple of that, any equivalent of that could be possible.
But the important thing is she's not smoking currently and she's also not a diabetic and
she has heavy plaque that's maybe not quite indicative of the destruction that she has
here in general.
So all those things considered, we go to our summary and so she has things that are more
in line with a stage three situation rather than a stage four.
She's more in line with a grade A situation and we said that it was a localized.
So we would call her a localized stage three grade A periodontitis patient.
All right case number three, so there's no clinical attachment loss measured this time.
So we need to go to the radiographs.
Now we notice some things might stick out, this vertical bone loss distal to tooth number
28.
There's some mesial and distal bone loss.
The tooth number three, some on four, eight has a significant bony defect.
And since premolars are involved here, we can't call this molar in size or pattern.
But this would be a localized pattern because less than 30% of the teeth are affected to
that level of severity.
The bone loss at these sites is probably at worst about maybe 40 or 50%, so that'll put
us automatically at a stage three or stage four.
This patient only lost one tooth to periodontitis, that's tooth number 25, which favors stage
three.
There's no mention of masticatory dysfunction or occlusal trauma or drifting or flaring.
That occlusion actually looks quite nice.
So we're pretty comfortably in a stage three situation here.
The 40 to 50% bone loss with age 60 puts us at a ratio slightly below one, so that looks
like a grade B.
And we have no other indicating factors listed here.
And remember, we always assume grade B, unless we have sufficient evidence to change to A
or C. So in this case, we don't, so we'll keep it at a grade B.
So this patient is a localized stage three, grade B, periodontitis.
Okay, and I have one more case for you guys.
Case number four, and a few things about this one should stick out right away.
No pun intended.
Her first or her chief complaint is the first thing we look at.
The gap between her two front teeth and that those two front teeth are starting to get
loose.
And now why might that be?
Well, if you look at the clinical photos, you can appreciate how subtle, but there's
some separation of those back teeth and these front teeth are banging together and there's
undoubtedly some heavy contact on those incisors.
And secondary occlusal trauma means that there's force on the teeth that usually they could
handle, but in the presence of periodontal attachment loss, it becomes traumatic.
And there's some good evidence for that happening here in this case.
There's some significant bone loss mostly by the upper incisors and this lower molar
for sure.
They had to take vertical bite wings just to capture how significant that bone loss was.
So this patient describes a molar incisor pattern.
We have bone loss at the incisors and the molars exclusively.
And I would classify this as stage four because of how significant that radiographic bone
loss is.
Again, we don't have clinical attachment to go off of, so we have to use bone loss on
the radiographs as a stand in or proxy.
As for her grating, she smokes less than 10 cigarettes a day, so that favors grade B.
But she has uncontrolled diabetes because her HBA1C is above 7%.
And just look at how much bone loss she has and look at her age, she's only 35 years old.
So this is for sure more than 35% bone loss.
So that radiographic bone loss to age ratio is greater than 1 in this case.
So between the uncontrolled diabetes and the rate of disease progression, more things are
favoring grade C than grade B in this case.
So for her, I'd classify it as molar and size or stage four grade C periodontitis.
And lastly, we have peri-implant diseases that go from peri-implant health to peri-implant
mucositis to peri-implantitis.
And risk factors and risk indicators for these disease processes include smoking, diabetes,
poor oral hygiene, poor compliance with supportive care, excess cement, lack of keratinized mucosa
around the implant, and peri-implantitis specifically, a history of previous peri-dontitis around
natural teeth.
There are also some genetic factors that can play a role in this progression.
So peri-implant health involves the absence of visual signs of inflammation and bleeding
on probing.
Implant assessment should consist of visual evaluation, some probing that should be done
at least once per year, evaluation of bleeding on probing of course, and evaluation of radiographic
bone levels compared to a baseline bone level at implant restoration.
It's not really possible to define healthy probing depths around implants, but in general,
peri-implant probing depths should be less than or equal to 5 millimeters.
And this is important that health is possible around implants with normal or reduced bone
support, just like with healthy gingiva on a reduced peridontium.
As long as you have an absence of progressive bone loss and no signs of inflammation, you
can have peri-implant health.
So this is the equivalent to our peri-dontal health that we saw before.
Every implant mucusitis involves the presence of visual signs of inflammation and bleeding
on probing.
So these signs are things like swelling and redness that you can see here.
Increasing probing depths compared to the baseline and absence of progressive marginal
peri-implant bone loss.
So basically this is like gingivitis, but around an implant.
Ever since that tooth was extracted, this tissue is no longer called gingivia.
It's called mucosa.
Hence the name peri-implant mucusitis rather than peri-implant gingivitis, but you can
think of it like gingivitis around an implant.
And then the third one was peri-implant titus.
This involves the presence of visual signs of inflammation and bleeding on probing.
That's the same, increased probing depths compared to baseline, that's the same, and
this is increased at one year post-implant restoration compared to whatever the baseline
probing depth was.
Now in the absence of a baseline recording, we're looking at probing depths that are six
millimeters or more, and radiographic evidence of three millimeters of bone loss or more.
In peri-implant titus, the big differentiating factor from peri-implant mucusitis is the
presence of progressive marginal peri-implant bone loss.
So this is really peri-dontitis around an implant because all these things are similar
to what we see in a peri-dontitis situation that we're just talking about around implants
instead of around natural teeth.
Now putting it all together, I made this summary slide.
The green x's means that you don't have one of these qualities, which is a good thing.
The red check means that you do have one of these four qualities, which is a bad thing.
So from health to mucusitis to peri-implant titus.
So the big changes for this 2018 AAP new peri-dontal classification, we have a new classification
of peri-dontitis, that's this multidimensional staging and greeting that we went over with
the definitions and through four case examples.
We have the consolidation of chronic and aggressive peri-dontitis into a single category.
And we have the addition of these peri-implant diseases and conditions and the clarification
of health and gingivitis on an intact versus a reduced peri-dontum with or without previous
peri-dontitis history.
Alright so that's it for this video guys, thank you so much for watching, please like
this video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to this channel for more on dentistry.
If you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do, please check out my Patreon
page.
Thank you to all of my patrons here for all of their support.
You can unlock extras like access to my video slides to take notes on and practice questions
for the board exams.
So go check that out, the link is in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone and I'll see you in the next video.